we have nine seconds estimated for the
macbook and then
what five minutes for this that's the
neural engine man all right that's
that's insane this is the m1's biggest
competitor from
china and today we have five brand new
tests that we've never done before
and in this comparison we're not only
going to take a look at the performance
the displays the keyboards the track
pads speakers
we're also going to look at real world
things such as thermal performance
photo and video editing gaming battery
life
and more the first thing that i want to
do is unplug these machines they are
both
at 100 battery life so we will be doing
a battery life comparison
while we do all of these real world
tests and i have to add that the
matebook x pro
has a 12 larger battery than our m1
macbook air so this is going to be
interesting
now we do have links to both of these
down in the video description if you
guys want to pick one up
and the macbook air could be bought
right now for 900
brand new with the warranty which is
crazy design and size wise they are very
similar if you're just looking at the
top at the cutouts the speaker grills
it's very interesting and then if we go
ahead and close them and stack the
macbook air on top of the mate book
they are very close in size as well the
matebook is slightly longer
and that's because of the display which
i'll talk about in just a bit and if we
take a look at the hinges
the sides the shape they are really
close one thing that's interesting is
that the matebook has a cutout slot
right here to suck in
air the same thing on the bottom just
like the macbook pro
of course the macbook air is fanless and
as far as ports on the left hand side
both have two thunderbolt ports
and the matebook has a headphone jack on
the left side as well whereas the m1
macbook air has it on the right
and the mate book also gives you one usb
type a port
which is very convenient both have easy
open
one-handed hinges and both do use
touch id or fingerprint sensors to log
in so i have the mac
and the mate book as far as the
keyboards the macbook air has a great
new magic
keyboard which fixes the previous
reliability issues it also feels
really nice to type on but with that
said
the matebooks keyboard is actually very
similar but i like it slightly
better because it has a little bit more
springiness in the actual keys making it
feel more like a mechanical keyboard
but both are awesome and moving down to
the track pads this is where it gets
interesting
we all know that macbooks have apple's
excellent force touch trackpad that's
magnetic
has a perfect feel all across the
trackpad very responsive
but huawei also created a magnetic
trackpad so it has the same even feel
all across it feels really good to click
to double click
as far as responsiveness it is excellent
so
i don't want to say it's as good as
apple's but it is very close in feel and
it is better than any other windows
trackpad i've ever used now before we
compare the webcams and the displays
which you guys might be already seeing a
major difference in
let's go ahead and compare the speakers
the speaker girls
look very similar almost identical now
the main book has quad speakers so let's
go ahead and do a comparison
and in our last video we said that we're
getting rid of the song but you guys
said no
we love this song we have to keep it so
let's get nostalgic
and take a listen to the song once again
let's compare these
wow that was interesting when we first
compared the 2019
matebook x pro against a macbook it
actually sounded better and was louder
than the macbook but now
well you guys let me know what your
thoughts are you guys heard that for
yourselves
i will just say the macbook air sounds
fantastic and it sounds even better
than the m1 macbook pro next let's take
a look
at these bezels the huawei looks awesome
with that super slim bezel on this
display
and one reason that they're able to pull
this off is because we do not have a
webcam
at the top of the screen like the
macbook does
instead it is hidden right here in the
keyboard and you can
close it for privacy and then pop it
open when you need to use it
so with that let's go ahead and compare
the quality of the webcam and
microphones this is huawei's 720p
webcam and microphone quality right now
i'm sitting at the normal
distance from a laptop and then if i
don't want my head to be cut off i do
have to move back
to about here and you guys let me know
if that changes the microphone quality
at all
and what you think of this lower camera
angle and this is the macbook air's the
720p
webcam and the quality of apple's
microphones you guys let me know which
one looked better and which one sounded
better
down in the comment section below now as
far as the screens the huawei has a 13.9
inch display
basically 14 inches which is kind of
what we're expecting from apple
soon here and the resolution is actually
higher as well it has a 3000 by 2000
resolution so 260 pixels per inch
so it's actually slightly more detailed
than apple's 218
with the macbook air and as far as
brightness the huawei
is also brighter as you guys could tell
from that top camera that i adjusted
it's rated at 450 nits compared to 400
for the macbook air
and the viewing angles are also better
on the matebook now when it comes to
color accuracy and contrast the macbook
screen is definitely better
we have full dci p3 color accuracy
and deeper blacks and then with that we
do have a big difference in reflectivity
the matebook access screen is very
reflective very glossy
so it does produce really sharp images
but even in this room which is not
that bright i see myself almost like a
mirror
compared to the macbook which has a
really good anti-glare coating
and now let's get into performance we're
going to start out with geekbench 5 i'm
going to go ahead and run the cpu
test now the matebook x pro comes with
intel's latest and greatest mobile
processor we have an i7
with g7 graphics and it goes all the way
up to 4.7 gigahertz
compared to 3.2 now of course the m1 is
an 8 core processor compared to a 4
core 8 thread but four of those cores
are very weak
efficiency cores so most of the
performance comes from four cores
alright guys we have our results and
keep in mind
we are doing this test on battery power
only
and we have a shocking difference of
basically
more than double in multi-core we have
213
difference with the macbook air just
killing it now as far as single core
the macbook air is about 32
faster now i went through all of the
power settings on
the huawei make sure there's no intel
settings no huawei settings
everything is set to full performance
this is just the performance that you
can expect
if you are unplugged now i kind of want
to plug it in and test more but we said
that this is going to be a battery test
real world so we're going to stick with
that and stick with this performance
and if you guys want to see the full
performance let us know down below in
the comment section if you guys want to
see a full review of this laptop
and now let's compare the graphics i'm
doing metal with geekbench 5 on the
macbook and we're going to run vulkan
that should be more optimized based on
what you guys are saying um
for the windows system and let's hit run
and here we go
this actually looks a lot better uh we
have 15
848 which is probably the highest i've
seen for these intel g7 graphics latest
ones
and then for metal of 18 912
so this is good news for a lot of these
real world tests that really rely now on
graphics and now it's time for our
second new test
and this is a brand new version of 3d
mark called
wild life extreme and it just came out
and it's cross-platform both for windows
for mobile devices and for m1 apple
silicon
machines and so we have them open right
here we have the unlimited mode toggled
which means that's the version designed
for the m1
chip and let's go ahead and hit run this
is interesting on the huawei we're
seeing the benchmark playback
looks like we're getting fps of about 20
to 22-ish
on the m1 it's running the off-screen
version of the test
it does say that it's running at 4k
resolution just like the other one
is and that it's optimized and designed
for cross platform
so i guess we're just going to let it
run and see what scores we get
all right we have our results and they
do kind of line up actually
we have 3077 score on the huawei and 446
on the m1 macbook air which is a
difference of about
44 or so and then as far as the frame
rate if we scroll down
uh the huawei got about 18.4 frames per
second compared to 26.6 so even though
this was running
off screen still at 4k the results do
kind of match up to our previous tests
and now let's go ahead and push these
machines to their limits with cinebench
but first i want to get a baseline
thermal reading it looks like the huawei
is hitting about 36 degrees celsius and
it's fairly even as far as the hot spot
on the keyboard
and our m1 macbook air is running at 29
degrees at its hottest spot and that's
actually
closer to the display there now with
that the matebook
actually has this vapor chamber designed
cooler that sucks in air from one side
and then blows it out towards the left
so it's going to be interesting how how
it actually gets
and let's go ahead and start our 10
minute multi-core
test now i also have intel power gadget
opened up right here so you can see
how much frequency does it actually hit
here on battery power
and it looks like with all the cores
maxed out it's only hitting about 2.5
gigahertz or so
and max at about 2.8 so definitely not
anywhere near that 4.7
now with that it is staying extremely
cool about 68 to 69 degrees
celsius whereas our macbook air was
already at 80 degrees and now it's
jumping up to 84
so it is definitely running hotter but
of course it does not have a fan
and now we only have about 45 seconds
left to go
and the huawei was actually quiet most
of the time until the very end and then
the fans kicked up even though it's not
running that hot
only 65 degrees celsius right now
compared to 95 on the m1 macbook air
because obviously it keeps heating up
and at this point starts thermal
throttling so let's go ahead and take a
look at the actual
temperatures of the machines uh the
huawei is at 38 degrees celsius so
barely any higher than before we started
the test
in our m1 macbook air right there at the
hottest spot it looks like we're getting
about
41 degrees celsius so definitely hotter
than the huawei
our macbook is finished and we have a
score of 7668 excellent score
we are waiting in the huawei it is
almost done and i'm curious
what kind of performance are we gonna
get when we are on battery power
and bam there we have it we have a score
of
3329 and that means that the m1 is 2.3
times faster
than the huawei with the best intel
laptop
processor when it's on battery power at
full load that is crazy and with that of
course we are still tracking
the battery life differences which we'll
talk about towards the end of this video
and now let's see how that cp
performance combines with the actual
good graphics performance in real world
tests
and this is our next real world test
that we added
we are actually using the lightroom
right now lightroom cc
which is optimized for apple silicon
looks like lightroom classic will never
be optimized
but this one is and it's cross platform
so we have 50 42 megapixel raw edited
images
here and we're gonna see how they
perform and how fast it takes to export
so let's go and switch the images bam
that was actually the same
speed there let's go next a little bit
faster on m1
a little bit faster on m1
quite a bit faster there so m1 is
definitely more responsive
let's go ahead and punch in to um
the actual image here
very similar performance oh i hit the
wrong button there and now let's select
all 50 of these edited images and we're
going to go ahead and export them and
see how long it takes
and bam we are off all right the m1 is
done it actually took
way longer than i expected and the
huawei is actually pretty close
and bam the huawei is finished so
it took the m1 macbook air four minutes
and 19
seconds and the huawei took five minutes
and 25 seconds
so definitely about 20 25 longer but not
as big of a difference as i expected and
now let's jump into our next test i have
the latest version of photoshop opened
up on both
and it is optimized for apple silicon
and we are going to take this 42
megapixel image
and run adobe's super resolution
feature that just came out we're going
to select enhance
and then we're going to select super
resolution all right so this one's
already done i actually didn't even
notice
how long it took less than 15 seconds i
might have to run that again
and the huawei what is going on did it
freeze up yeah it looks like it did
freeze i can't really
control anything it just just was stuck
here
all right we have two new images ready
to do this no way i just noticed that it
says
five minutes estimated time compared to
nine
seconds nah dude that's wrong i wonder
if that's the machine learning
in the m1 chip dude that's that's the
neural engine man the neural engine
that's what it is look how fast it
updates
watch enhanced as soon as i move it it
shows me the enhanced image it's just
enhancing a tiny portion
and then here watch i'm gonna move it
and we're sitting waiting
waiting waiting still waiting
and then it shows the enhance that's the
difference all right but anyways let's
go ahead and hit this button
and we'll wait and see how long it takes
done bam okay
that was fast that actually took 13
seconds so a little bit longer than the
nine
thankfully it didn't freeze up this time
well actually
i think i have to like not touch
anything as soon as i start moving the
cursor
it starts freezing up right it is
running and we're gonna wait
all right guys it has been over 10
minutes
and we are still waiting it's still
processing
the fans have spun up so it's getting
hot it's getting loud
and it's still going so of course we had
an estimate of about five minutes it's
over ten
the macbook had to estimate oh is that
done oh yep it just got done
all right we just got done 10 minutes
and 36
seconds is how long it took so that just
shows you the power
of that neural chip that's built in that
is just insane
and for our next new test we're gonna
merge nine images
into hdr so this is also going to push
the graphics and the cpus
let's go ahead and select merged hdr on
here it's interesting that the m1
macbook air is only using 17
of the cpu and 15 graphics
compared to here we have about 19
graphics and 23
cpu and with that we're using 10.6 gigs
of ram out of 16 on the huawei
whereas our macbook air only has eight
gigs this is the base model
for all of these tests all right our m1
is done
so it looks like this status bar really
doesn't mean nothing because they were
kind of stuck
for a while and then bam it just gets
finished all right we just got
done we have our previews of the hdr on
both
both images look similar they look good
but we have a massive difference in time
the m1 macbook air took a minute and 38
seconds
and go ahead and comment down below how
long do you think
that our intel based huawei mate book
took i'll hold on a second i'll give you
guys some time to comment your estimate
all right uh make sure you guys wrote
below
this took four minutes and 15
seconds so that is pretty much what
three times longer
alright and now for our final test we
have video editing
i have the latest version of davinci
resolve studio opened up
and as you guys saw as far as graphics
performance which is what is really
heavily used
for this test even unplugged the
performance was great and these tiger
lake chips
have the latest encoders as well so this
is a 4k project with two lights applied
and some film grain let's go ahead and
hit the space bar to see how this will
play back
i'm gonna mute this so the macbook is
playing back perfectly at 24
frames per second whereas on the huawei
you guys see all of that stuttering
right over there so it cannot handle
playing back this project with these
kind of more basic effects i'm gonna go
ahead and just stop this and before we
do the export i'll go into this color
tab
this should tell us the actual frame
rate that it's capable of
playing back at let's hit play
and it looks like oh gosh that's not
very good
okay so it looks like we're getting
about 10 11 frames per second just 12
there for a split second
whereas our macbook bam we're playing
back perfect 24 frames per second we
still have
some graphics performance left over for
other effects
and now let's go ahead and export this
five minute project the settings are all
the same
let's hit go and it's interesting that
now that we're exporting
we're actually exporting at 41 frames
per second because we don't need to play
back at perfectly 24
whereas with the mate book we're
exporting at 11
10 and a half basically the full
performance it could give
and bam the m1 macbook air is done two
minutes and 53 seconds while we have
eight minutes
and 25 seconds remaining on the huawei
this thing is only about 26 done when
our m1 macbook air was finished and i
don't know if i want to wait
another over eight minutes so
realistically
it's going down consistently with this
timer so it's going to take about 11
minutes and 20 seconds to about 11
minutes and 30 seconds
compared to under three so that is just
an absolute massive
difference all right guys let's go and
shut this down and
let's talk about our final test that
we've never done before comparing a
macbook to a windows laptop
in terms of real-world battery life this
is going to be interesting once again as
a reminder
the huawei has a battery that's about 12
larger
than the m1 macbook airs and as far as
the displays we kept the brightness
the same even though this one can get
brighter and
we've been shooting for approximately
how long vadim
i'd say about three and a half hours or
so you know some tests we had to redo we
had to download some stuff there's cuts
and you know
in between this video's cut down a lot
but everything has been done
identically on both of these machines
the macbook
is at 62 battery life
62 really good after all of those high
performance tasks
that's great and you guys go and comment
down below what do you think the huawei
is at we have 62 over here what do you
expect here i'll give you guys a few
seconds
all right the huawei is at 15
battery and it's showing 55 minutes
remaining
if we're just sitting here at the
desktop so 15
compared to 62 here we have more than
half
battery remaining here we are very close
to the battery
dying that is a shocking difference and
let this be known that
with this test the cpu was throttling
down quite a bit
we're not running anywhere near 25 watts
or 30 watts or
4.7 gigahertz we're running at 2.3 2.6
in order to save power to help battery
life
and then of course you guys saw the
performance differences with all those
real world tests
um yeah that just speaks for for itself
and
realistically if you guys want windows
on uh your system
you can run parallels vadim actually did
a great video on the performance with
parallels and
how to install it we'll have that video
right over there once again we have
links down in the video description a
great deal on this m1 macbook air
click that circle above if you guys want
to subscribe and help us reach 1 million
subscribers before the end of this year
we would highly appreciate it
this max and we'll see you in the next
[Music]
video